thank you
[Music]
so um
We're Not Gonna really go into this
because it's just like
there's just no way to go into this
there's there was another shooting oh
man it was at olive oil in Norway it was
at a gay bar wow oh [ __ ] people died how
many two I believe and several other
people were wait I thought guns were
illegal in Norway no Norway I know okay
uh okay yes we're not gonna go into that
what we are going to go into is based on
our current understanding
without looking anything up I just want
to hear from you guys what do you think
you're supposed to do during a mass
shooting [ __ ] stop drop and roll out
of there
am I you're still up too
um no you're just in a crowd and there's
a shooting I'm in a massive crowd yeah I
mean usually if it's a mass shooting
there's gonna be more than I'm in a
minute a five-person crowd
it depends yeah where I am like if it's
like a concert
is it a classroom is it like a fast food
place okay let's say concert okay drop
am I on the outside or am I in the
middle
middle I have no [ __ ] Choice it's
where the crowd is going at this point
the usual protocol is uh regardless of
where you're at you're trying to seek
cover and concealment number one and the
difference is concealment is you can't
see but that's not cover so like
concealment could be like oh you can't
see me maybe a blaster you're still
gonna shoot you in the face so cover is
like behind the thickness yeah yeah good
yeah but if you're in a mass crowd and
you're in the middle of it like you
really don't have many options yeah you
have to get there as fast the crowd is
the cover yeah you have to get there as
fast as you can and then I probably
phone the author not the second step I'd
phone the authorities
so the first it's crazy that we have to
know exactly what that protocol is
though yeah like we should know about we
should we used to do [ __ ] earthquake
and fire drills now kids are doing mass
shooting exactly it just shows the how
everything changes [ __ ] run and
zigzags yo that's the that's the first
and best option right it says to run I'm
pretty good at this [ __ ] run away from
the run in zigzags no run yeah but
zigzag or wave is simply just to get out
obviously like that's not gonna be
readily available but that is your best
option if you can do it uh and this
instructional here it says that people
have been completely blown away just
standing by the door frozen yeah so if
you can go through the door to another
room another place yeah just go that's
the first one don't freeze what else
would you guys do just run
in Nevada if I'm in Nevada I can
immediately return fire
oh [ __ ] that's cool well if you don't
know where the shots are coming from
low to the ground load the ground I
closed my eyes ago
they're probably gonna shoot
that's what that was
like bat sonar I don't know
there's guns blowing off everything
volume everywhere I go
trying to echolocation
okay so another one says choose a route
carefully I mean this is kind of like
running but yeah it says don't run don't
run until you've chosen a route like
don't just go like look where you're
gonna go yeah cause you might be running
toward the shooter go yeah
um and another one is think
unconventionally if there's a window you
can break break the [ __ ] out of that
window and dive roll out dang Death By
Glass
I guess you have a higher chance of
surviving
I'd rather get an injury than bugging
the further you are away from someone
with a firearm the less accurate they
are so it's really important to get
distance yeah this even says uh you may
even be able to punch through drywall
between rooms whoa Bart can't do that
bro I mean those are these walls as long
as you don't hit first you gotta go like
this though
foreign
[Laughter]
but also how many punches that takes
before you can make it to the other side
yeah not if you train with me I'm not
sure if that's the best course of action
nce It also says don't make sure that
you're you know like the what is it
after two floors up
The Falls are more likely to be fatal
after two floors yeah so if you're two
floors up [ __ ] dive out the window
even though you're like a whole story up
but past that oh yeah that's true you
might break some bones but right but
you'll get out but third story so don't
let being up one story stop you from
just launching yeah it's like the guys
at the bottom of the stairs you're like
how do I get out you know it's like
[ __ ] like even if like let's say that
was the case like if there was like a
stairwell that like everyone was going
down and like and it's just one story up
you're better off just launching out the
window then going down that stairwell
but not everyone does parkour so it's
hard for them to kind of like picture I
think it's I think it's life or death
that's what it's meant to be though like
you don't know what he does who do you
know that does parkour
I know or yeah take off all your clothes
and he throw it on the floor first when
you Landing up padding that's true
that's what it's meant to be is that you
don't have to know parkour at two floors
you probably won't die if you just jump
out over your bed and you'll probably
get [ __ ] up and have soft knees which
will be out of there yeah try to drop
and roll let the parkour guys try not to
land with the legs [ __ ] straight line
yeah
break your legs can't run everybody gets
out that the shooter just walks up to
you outside and then I'll show you the
thing you said about staying low is your
key thing too is to stay low and try to
take paths that don't cause sounds like
it says don't uh don't go down a
Stairway if it's creaking like just wait
don't go down like certain paths if
they're like you know if they can your
presence can be alerted
or just conceal carry yeah
shoot yourself
that's what I don't know
the cover and concealment thing too and
your evacuation you also want to make
one intelligent Choice after another so
if you can instead of just like looking
at one giant far exit and I'm just gonna
run towards there like like let's say
you're at like uh I don't know like a
big park or campus or whatever like oh
cool there's a concrete bench there
there's that over here there's that over
here so that way you minimize your risk
as you're going rapid yeah rather than
oh there's the exit and it's just
literally a straight line and you're
completely vulnerable the whole way if
you can get cover every single step but
like American Gladiators Yeah Yeah from
your training do you still innately
think like that like do you see the
world like differently it's been a long
time but there's still like little bits
of things in there because you drill it
right do you go to a restaurant and have
to have your
face towards the entrance no no you can
sit wherever yeah he has his face inside
the waffles and eggs
[Laughter]
he's preoccupied remember how we had
like Dawn here uh who's like you know
most gangster heartthobs sexiest like
military Raider type stuff right and uh
super skilled but he even mentioned like
when you're out there when you actually
we're talking about like trained you
know uh soldiers and stuff yeah um I
asked him I asked him he's like yeah
maybe like 30 some percent or a third
are like [ __ ] down like they want to
go into the firefight right maybe a
third will kind of just react rationally
or with their training and maybe a third
will like freeze yeah and like those are
like people with training you know what
I mean like I I can't say that I've ever
been in that situation but I can also
imagine myself freezing even if I know
all the answers fear exactly so I feel
like that's almost the first thing to
try and train versus just knowing I
think obviously having the knowledge is
half the training that's right that
drilling is so important exactly when
[ __ ] happens if you're thinking you're
[ __ ] it needs to just be muscle memory
and your body's just executing and kind
of putting yourself in like simulated
high stress situations to see how well
you could perform especially if it's
like
like sometimes even comparing I know
this is going to be something crazy but
like putting yourself in like a combat
situation like a jiu jitsu tournament
where there's high stakes really high
stress obviously that's not going to
compare to anything like a [ __ ]
shooting but it's closer than your
civilian regulations yeah because you
need to feel like you need to perform in
a high stress situation are you
marketing your stuff train at Lionheart
Academy that I won't be filming so what
do you guys think happens you need to
buy some noodles Before You Escape
[Laughter]
to what Nick is saying um the number one
biggest thing aside from all the
training Drilling and all that stuff the
number one biggest thing when [ __ ] hits
the fan is uh adrenaline management oh
that's the number one thing the minute
your heart rate is here literally
everything in your brain is through the
roof yeah you're not thinking and even
like maybe under a normal circumstance
you can run over there now your heart
rate is already at Peak heart rate like
your distance is like a third of what
you think so it's like a dream run yeah
oh I know so what do you guys think
happens let's say a mass shooting occurs
you're in a room and you can't go out
what do you do then you try to block the
doors right that's right yeah that's the
first thing I've been right every time
you're good dude block the door anything
big and heavy wedge objects under the
farthest point from the hinges that's
important too say that again one more
time somebody there's actually a video
of a guy who takes a chair similar to
this and puts it in between the door
handle so that way the person can't open
the door yeah and you want to create
make it as thick as possible too because
you want to stop bullets okay right
right and turn off the light
like nobody's there nobody's home
silence your phones which might be
really hard to remember obviously if
your adrenaline is going oh that's
always what happens in the horn it's
like it goes and it's like all the back
I can hear it but that's also why like
with these scenarios if they could be
drilled it helps out because like in the
military what's dope is you already have
assigned like hierarchy and almost like
plays like rolls right roles exactly
right so something hits the like let's
say go boom contact left everyone
understands where the fire is coming
from you block hit the door you go
whatever you go whatever so things are
happening simultaneously which is
[ __ ] dope and they're structure and
organized versus just 20 chickens with
their hair chaos yeah yeah that always
reminds you of Lone Survivor when
they're on the cliff and they're like
fighting all those just the four of them
yeah and everyone has like a job a very
clear job yeah yeah or like Dwight in
the office yeah
or Michael in the office yeah nobody
panic
yeah so once you once you got all that
stuff done choose a hiding place and
that's when you make your next plan uh
once you're as small of a Target as
possible yeah that's crazy let's say the
guy busts it what's next now
I got flaming hot Cheetos in my fingers
it's actually right yeah you do fight
that's what you do you fight nope Last
Resort dangerous option but that's what
this is
like I'm confused though
while he's doing that Nick's grabbing
grab it
I missed look it's going like this
come here continue
he drops his gun you're about to attack
him he does it to you
obviously this is like if you're in the
room with several people then this is
gonna apply to you but create chaos is
uh the next instruction don't be an easy
target swarm yeah the way like when bees
try to kill that big ass Hornet like
sworn violence of action throw [ __ ]
everything you got yeah because if
you're all running away at the same time
he's just shooting backs yeah and then
move the weapon away it's the extreming
like why how would people would want to
run at him like it like untrained people
that's scary you know but remember the
shooter in um that Taiwanese yeah yeah
yeah that one doctor he just charged his
ass but it only took one Brave dude
where everyone else dog piled afterwards
the person's not expecting that yeah
yeah and it does suck that like you know
the odds are that person may not make it
because they're the one taking the
initiative that's why no one wants to be
the first yeah but that's that's the
nobility in that [ __ ] you're right like
let's say there's like a creepy dude
like uh this violence like speed of
action just a lot of overwhelming like
like vital shots will make a guy go up
with like even if they're like six four
or three hundred just like a b think
like a b yeah it's like if you just
swarmed them the speed of action makes
them have to think and they have to
react yeah they have to react and they
have to go what's my answer because now
there's new stimuli yeah yeah yeah is
that the why sometimes the Box matches
when they're about to touch gloves the
guy doesn't do it and just towards him
that's something bad speed of action
speed of action heard this from bark on
JK hey Texas Clubhouse
yeah that's definitely what you do the
last and final thing really is attack so
uh once you guys are all swarming and
everyone's that's the thing it's like
cooperation too you know like you can't
organize that this is so like if this is
a perfect case scenario I would just say
like the first rule of thumb is like if
you can run run in a zigzag formation
you know what's [ __ ] dope so uh Tim
Kennedy he's like uh like super special
these I guess GI Joe as it comes right
so he understands all like tactical
weapons taxes [ __ ] diving jumping on
airplanes [ __ ] he set up a new like
Elementary School in
um in Texas
and the way they have it set up there's
no outside windows that face like the
outside I mean no windows of the
classroom that face the outside so if
you're a creeper or whatever trying to
see what's going on you'll never be able
to see what's going on there's only one
way into the school and the way the
first way into the school is a kill box
Lobby whoa so there's as soon as you
come in if since since all the teachers
are firearm trained if they want to it's
just a kill zone right there like you
come in and you're not you're not a
welcome person people are shooting you
at multiple directions and it's gonna be
extremely hard for you to return fires
yeah I'm like they should get like the
military to just redesign the ergonomics
of schools because that's [ __ ] sick
yeah wow you know what I mean every
school in the US is a bunker Now isn't
that the same thing with like the
Israeli airport because the Israeli
airport has bomb threats on The Daily
that they do the interrogations in rooms
where if the bomb went off it wouldn't
hurt anyone it's like the room is
designed line to just contain the
explosion that's [ __ ] wow isn't that
[ __ ] crazy that they designed that
way though they're like yo it's just
crazy the the level of like security
that exists that we don't even know yeah
where we just go into all these
buildings what the [ __ ] is this extra
room
and then they plan all that out it was
this empty Lobby and you're like yo
those drapes they don't match man we're
just we're just speaking well the drape
should still match the kill box
that's not an excuse yeah that's the
reality of today so hopefully people are
being trained well or at least yeah we
got to be aware at least you know hard
thing to [ __ ] ask of course for real
but damn it's better than nothing though
right we have seen people with that in
mind and just like the Taiwanese uh
Church
that guy had that on his mind and he
saved a lot of people for it